[Music]
we are here today to discuss nature
friend or foe so
most think of nature as good
while humans and human interventions are
often seen as public problematic and
even on occasion evil
from eradicating e numbers from our diet
to refusing vaccines
many are motivated by the idea that
nature knows best
and yet malaria is natural
the malaria vaccine is not
crop failure hurricanes tsunamis all are
deadly
and all are natural
human actions are essential to extend
and save lives from natural calamity
so is our attachment to nature
undermining belief in ourselves
should we have more faith in human and
less trust in nature or are we right to
be skeptical of human intervention and
should we see the renewed reverence for
nature as a positive return to an
ancient and essential belief
then again should we accept that we are
part of the natural world and give up on
the false distinction between real and
artificial
natural and unnatural
so with that to our illustrious speakers
to my right and through the power of the
internet
uh a human intervention yuval noah
harari is a world-renowned public
intellectual and historian he is the
author of international bestsellers such
as sapiens a brief history of humankind
and homo deus a brief history of the
future his books have sold more than 20
million copies worldwide
to my left i have the pleasure of
introducing slavoy zizek who is a
hegelian psychoanalyst and arguably the
leading celebrity philosopher of our
times
idiosyncratic
and fiercely polemical apparently slavoy
is currently serving as international
director of the birkbeck institute for
humanities not that you could tell from
the way he's dressed
uh foreign policy named giusek a top 100
global thinker for giving voice to an
era of absurdity but what i'm going to
do in fact is um ask both of these
speakers an opening question which is
should we have more faith in the human
and less trust in nature yuval i trust
you've heard every word that i've said
because i can barely see you on this
screen fabulous joining us from the
ether please could you take it away you
have three minutes to tell us whether or
not we should have more faith in the
human and less trust in nature
well um
two things to say about nature one is
that nature doesn't care about us in
particular i mean if an asteroid would
hit planet earth tomorrow morning and
all life on earth will be destroyed
nature wouldn't care about it it would
just go on as usual planets and stars
explode all the time and physics just
goes on
the second point is that you know it's
really
i never really know what to say about
this seeming binary division between
humans and nature because you can never
violate the laws of nature nothing that
humans or anybody else can do
can break the laws of nature anything
which is possible is by definition also
natural
whether it's genetic engineering whether
it's the internet whether it's
vaccinations it's all natural
because you know the laws of nature are
not like the laws of a state
the state makes a low let's say you
can't drive more than 90 kilometers per
hour that's the law of the state and you
nevertheless drive 120 kilometers per
hour and a policeman stops you and gives
you a ticket a fine it doesn't work like
that with nature nature it doesn't
give us some kind of flow and then if we
break it i don't know we do genetic
engineering and then it punishes us for
it for this it just doesn't work like
that
so
um i'm again i think we should be
suspicious both of humans and of nature
and the big question to ask
about anything is not whether it is
natural everything is natural the big
question to ask is whether it causes
suffering it causes harm wars are
natural but they are still bad
and uh
climate change is bad not because it's
somehow against nature but because it
potentially would cause immense
suffering to humans and to other
sentient beings so that's the big
question fascinating okay well slavoy uh
what do you think do you think we should
have more faith in humans do you think
we should trust nature less do you want
to tell you while he's wrong
no i have a big problem here because uh
where are the knives i basically agree
with what you've
just said i mean no because i
i know he's often accused of being like
too popular but i think he is saying
things
nonetheless in a clear serious way and
what more fascinates me is to what
extent
even if we rationally accept this and
know
we don't
really believe into it i think this is
even i wonder if you would agree what in
psychoanalysis we call fetishist split
in french the sabian mecca meme i know
this how things are but somehow in me i
am not convinced i think that's the
problem with ecology yeah i know what
science says but you know you go outside
here sun is shining
lately so quickly quickly well yes i
agree with him first
all is nature of course
but here comes one i hope you all will
agree a tricky point we nonetheless
deep in our i call it as an old marxist
everyday ideology we nonetheless usually
associate with nature a certain more or
less regular pattern
rhythm
so that
and this is what i
radically reject this idea that there is
some natural pattern and we humans with
our hubris excessive exploitation or
what we are disturbing this pattern more
on this later i would like to remind you
along the lines of what you are hinted i
think listen are just think about what
are today our main sources of energy
still coal and oil
can you even imagine what mega
catastrophe
must have happened on our earth
for us to have this we are a consequence
of natural i mean a consequence we live
of natural uh disasters
that's the last thing i wonder how you
all will respond i read recently in
even in the big media that now according
to the latest news even this vision of
global warming it's too optimist because
it somehow implies that there will be a
new regular pattern just a little bit
worse temperatures higher a couple of
cities
big cities under the sea but it will be
a new pattern the predictions now says
what if and it happens often in nature
what if there will be no new pattern but
as it happens in nature again for a long
time we will live in a much more
radically chaotic universe so nature is
everything just to finish i know you can
count on my other minutes but let's not
forget that in some sense don't be
afraid i'm a naturalist i'm not uh
i'm not an idealist that nature is
everything all the catastrophes also
come from nature so sorry for a small
vulgarity if we have a mother nature
this mother is a dirty big let's face it
there we go
just the opposite but everything is also
culture not in the idealist sense but in
the sense just look at the history of
the notion of nature how it
changes nature was in medieval times
something totally different than modern
nature from sciences today something
different now i'm not saying nature is
just a cultural construct i'm just
saying that what we perceive as natural
is always part of a cultural process to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you